each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay what's it it's a it's a pleasure to
have Sardar to see Ron visiting us again
he'll be here for the entire week he's
been a frequent visitor to Microsoft
Research currently he's a professor at
coach University and in in Istanbul
Turkey and he's interested in both
dynamic and Static verification of of
concurrent programs and today he's going
to tell us about his work on
compositional verification of verifying
transactional memory implementations
okay thank you for us excuse me this is
more of a progress report on a project i
started last summer i believe so yes and
the project is on verifying software
transactional memory implementations and
a compositional method for doing so I
don't there aren't that many repeat
clients so i guess i will repeat the
part that i did last summer as well so
software transactional memory makes
available and a programming primitive to
programmers they get to mark code blocks
atomic and sh t aime implementation
automatically guarantees that excuse me
that these blocks appear to be executed
in an atomic serialized non-blocking way
and these atomic blocks are composable
this of course shifts the difficulty of
concurrent programming to the STM
implementer they have to implement both
optimal high performance and code that
is also correct this code has to do
conflict detection rollback ordering and
other complicated things but the hope is
that transactional memory will be a
widely adopted abstraction therefore its
correctness is as critical as other
parts of your computing platforms such
as your run
I am your compiler your processor and
therefore it is important to get
implementations of transactional memory
right real industrial scale
are on the order of ten thousands tens
of thousands of lines of code and they
interact in complicated ways with the
rest of the runtime the operating system
garbage collector etc therefore their
verification is not a very
straightforward easy task for today's
verification tools and the goal of this
project was to devise a modular reusable
method if you are if you're developing
another STM implementation the goal was
for you to be able to use and reuse
parts of this approach and the goal is
again to mechanically check the most
error-prone parts but do some of the
proof manually still and the key idea
underlying the approach is that there
are a few approaches to building STM's
at the algorithm level at this level STM
implementations are well understood and
the key ideas in their correctness proof
although they are not what always
written in the most formal way they're
well understood and at this level at the
algorithm level the model of an
execution consists of large grain atomic
x actions such as field writes field
reads and transactions committing or
rolling back and for instance if you
look at ppl di paper and the
transactions paper and the bartok HTM
there is a intuitive correctness proof
written at this level so the idea of the
work that got started last summer was to
do this algorithm level proof once using
manual techniques mostly and to
translate the proof to boil it down to a
number of sufficient conditions which
guarantee correctness and then the idea
is in this case these three properties
would be checked of the STM
implementation and if the STM
implementation satisfies these
properties then you're guaranteed that
you get for instance serialize ability
and
a good thing about the approach that we
worked on last time last summer was that
each of these sufficient conditions
could be formulated as a sequential
assertion check which then we could hand
off to boogie and verify or find bugs in
unfortunately the picture isn't as clean
as this slide would may lead you to
believe because the executions at the
implementation level are more
complicated than than the ones in the
previous slide with large atomic actions
the complication comes from two factors
one there are more variables that you
need to be concerned with at the
implementation level there are variables
that come from the STM implementation
that implement for instance the
transaction logs the metadata associated
with each object etc also at this more
realistic model modeling level there are
finer grain smaller atomic actions
therefore a lot more interleaving to
consider an atomic action at this level
is pretty much what the programming
language gives you as an atomic action
one instruction in an STM function
implementation therefore reasoning at
this level with these fine grain actions
and with this many variables it's
difficult and I serializability proof or
a correctness proof of whatever criteria
you desire would be a lot more messy to
write and check and it would be a lot
more error-prone so the approach I'm
going to talk to you about today is
aimed at defining and proving a
correspondence between these finer grain
interleaved executions at the
implementation level and the algorithm
level executions with bigger atomic
blocks and at the end of this the
algorithm level proof of correctness
will carry over to implementation level
executions which is what you would want
and in pictures what how try to go
through today is to start with an
implementation level execution to model
it and also to model an algorithm level
execution satisfying these desired
properties
to go from here to there through a
series of transformation steps at this
point I don't want I don't expect you to
read and understand all this text just
pay attention to the four big gray
arrows think of each of those as a way
of transforming a detailed execution at
this level to a more abstract execution
at this level now each of these gray
arrows looks pictorially again like this
imagine that each color is an action by
a transaction a different transaction
black would be one transaction red would
be another etc and at the implementation
level they would be very interesting the
bottom here and each transformation step
would do some abstraction which would
allow more actions to commute while
leaving the execution the coolant to the
original one you would prove none
interference between certain actions
which would again allow you to realize
that there are bigger atomic clocks and
at the end you would get larger atomic
clocks and then you would repeat
transformation of this sort to get even
bigger atomic blocks and the goal would
be at the very top level to get
transactions as your biggest atomic
clocks now what I'll talk about is the
formalization of what I showed you in
pictures to talk about algorithm level
and implementation level execution so I
will define a very simple language which
is transaction heavy but otherwise
doesn't have a lot of the complicated
other features of programming language
and for this language I will define to
cement two different semantics one is at
this level the other one is at the
implementation level I'll formalize what
correctness means on this language and
I'll show you a picture of the algorithm
level proof which is distilled to three
required properties the bulk of today's
talk will be about relating x
tuitions at the implementation level and
at the algorithm level and I'll focus on
what needs to be abstracted and what
needs to be verified at the
implementation level and I'll conclude
so here is our transactional
featherweight Java and the things to pay
attention to are there are statements
and there are statements well there are
statements that are allowed to be inside
transactions and there are statements
that are not allowed to be inside
transactions in particular you're not
allowed to spawn another threat while
you're inside the transaction you can
spawn as many threads as you want but
that can't be inside the transaction and
this statement that starts with on acid
and ends with commit is the transaction
construct whatever is in between it
executes right I didn't think that this
I wish I had and each transaction is
labeled other than that you don't have
much you have assignment you have method
calls you have sequential composition
and you have classes fields and methods
and you have parallel composition begin
transaction and transaction but the
inventor of transactional featherweight
Java had picked those keywords and I
built on it and removed from it thank
thank you for this thank you thank you
for the suggestion any other suggestions
yeah nothing will in sequential
composition inside of a transaction
so yeah no no it's a lot you are allowed
to do that it's just transactional
featherweight Java models sequential
composition with actually a method call
the arguments to the method call are
evaluated before the method itself and
in my effort at fixing that I put it
here but not here thank you for the
correction so it shows that this work is
not in its final form its work in
progress and this is a report on
progress since last summer so yes you
are allowed sequential composition of
course inside transactions otherwise
they'd be trivial okay so um the purpose
of this slide is to make you believe
that there is actually formal semantics
I associated with with this language and
this slide as well and this slide as
well but of course I'll tell you again
in pictures what the ugh yes right so
that will eventually be in the technical
report we're going to write about this
um but um pictorially or intuitively at
the high level i model the program and
STM composition in the following way I
don't model the inside of the SDM
implementation the STM has the purpose
of telling the program whether it's okay
to commit a transaction whether it's not
okay to commit the transaction and then
also to undo some actions it's done as
part of a transaction the program when
it's about to begin a transaction
notifies the implementation and when
it's going to do a field right or if
you'll read it notifies the STM
implementation when it wants to commit a
transaction it asks if it's okay to
commit if it not if it's not it has to
roll back the transaction and it does so
just one second by the the STM
implementation telling it step by step
to roll back the last action I'm going
to show pictures about each of these
bullets
team had this relates to your premium
sides of the formal semantics do you
describe the semantics of the OT FJ
program as an atomic on that can t make
these commands and receive responses or
what's the connection so let's look here
for instance for instance when you're
doing a reed field first the STM
implementation takes an action and the
STM state is transformed so in the
semantics you have program state and STM
state separately it's a tuple that has
both of those and program state is store
for also a context for each transaction
and transactions can be nested etc so
it's sort of a complicated tuple but you
have a program state and an STM state
and for each each OT FJ statement you
describe what that translates to these
state transitions states yes and maybe I
should immediately jump to the picture
so those two arrows again pictorial
correspond to first the STM state making
a transition registering the open for
read request and then in the program
state makes a transition that
corresponds to the reaction and also the
program at this level at this algorithm
level and keeps its own log about what
it did inside the transaction for
instance if it did i read it has its own
log of and why I chose to model this is
a very sort of intricate matter maybe
that we can discuss afterwards and how
the STM implementation transforms the
state in response to this request is
left unspecified at this level and all
we're going to ask at the end of the STM
at this level is to tell us when it's
okay to commit when it's not okay to
commit how it does so is its own
business and similarly with a field
write the program asks if the STM if
it's
k too right I'm actually sends an open
for write request the stn tells it
whether it's okay to write or not if it
is then it writes and then it adds to
its log the old and the new value of
field that is writing to see MJ in
reality yes of course but at this level
we're pretending that the program keeps
a record that pretty much a linked list
of what it did inside the transaction
and when the STM says no you can't
commit this transaction it rolls back on
its own so at this level my goal was to
keep the STM state unspecified as much
as possible so that the proof would boil
down to these three requirements and
from the STM but in reality in bartok
for instance the STM has a slog and then
it says each undo action is communicated
to the program and STM tells the program
please undo this please undo that that's
it there and transaction commits is if
at the stn says it's okay to commit it
updates its state than the program
updated state and the logs if it's a
nested transaction are appended to the
parent transaction otherwise if it's a
top-level transaction logs are discarded
the rollback is the trickiest if the STM
says it's not okay to commit this
transaction because of conflict then
together the program and the STM take a
sequence of transitions think of each of
these as an undue last log entry order
from the STM to the program and at the
end of this sequence of events STM has
finished its undoing of the transaction
and the program has reversed all the
actions in the log and it's as if the
transaction can be retried from the
beginning of the transaction again yes
on the programs that are expecting on
that so in reality of course like i said
it's it's on the STM side but while
defining the semantics here and when
while doing the the serializable 80
proof in order to say here are the three
requirements from the STM but the logs
are kept in the following manner in the
program it was more convenient to do so
like I said I realize that's not a very
convincing answer right now but the
longer version is about five minutes
long so um by the way um like I said oh
T FJ bills and transactional
featherweight Java but tfj is atomic at
a much bigger level um conflicts are not
allowed to occur the entire transaction
execute in one go so this is um by some
others definitions actually a low level
semantics already because it allows
conflicts it allows rollbacks and then
it allows retries of transactions and
just remind you each of those slides the
story in each of those slides is
considered atomic at this level for
instance and open for read requests
followed by a field read or open for
right followed by a field right or the
rollback of an entire transaction is
considered one atomic sequence of events
at this level and to define correctness
at this level and we first defined
equivalence of executions two executions
are equivalent if they have the same set
of threads they end at the same program
state and when you project the actions
to each thread each thread is doing
really the same sequence of actions only
the interleaving is different and both
of those have to be traces of this
program obviously an alternative view at
looking at equivalence is to say if you
can obtain one execution from another by
swapping independent actions that are
adjacent then you get an equivalent
execution we're dependent means two
accesses access the same variable and at
least one is a right at the simple level
we also define something called
equivalence modular undos it means look
at two executions remove all actions
that rollback transactions do get rid of
rollback transactions pretend they
didn't happen if the leftover executions
are equivalent in the way I define the
rather than tweak executions are
equivalent modular undos now correctness
is um
defined as serializability and this has
to do with a serial execution where if
in the execution there are two actions
by the same transaction separated like
this and if in between them there is
another action then this red action has
to either belong to TX or a child of TX
a transaction nested inside it it can't
belong to an upper level or a
transaction done by another threat
conflict three means no transaction
needed to be rolled back no transactions
ever experienced a conflict and a purely
serial execution is an execution that's
cereal and conflict free now serialize
ability is the requirement that each
execution of this program is TM combo is
equivalent to a serial execution and
pure serialize ability is of the
requirement that each execution be
equivalent modular undos to a purely
serial execution ok so that's
correctness and with this definition of
correctness and with this model at the
algorithm level these three conditions
constitute a sufficient condition for
pure serialize ability of of an STM
implementation between an open for write
request and the corresponding commit or
undo no other transaction should write
to the object that we're concerned with
here this is the exclusive rights
property the valid reads property says
between the time that a transaction
opened an object for read and it
successfully committed the transaction
obj should not be modified by another
transaction another transaction meaning
another transaction not nested inside
this one and the correct undos property
says the state of an object that is
rolled back in in a rollback trans
action the state should right before the
open for update and the state right
after the undo should be the same so
this is the property that you did the
undos correctly okay then if your STM
satisfies these three conditions
altogether then you're guaranteed pure
serializability but remember this proof
is at the algorithm level with with the
big large atomic actions okay now our
goal is to relate implementation and
algorithm level executions so that these
three conditions can now be can now act
as a sufficient condition for
correctness at the implementation level
so let's start at the implementation
level and do one transformation but what
is the implementation level semantics
the program actions that are reads and
writes etc I don't need to refine those
any further they're as they're the same
in the algorithm level and at the
implementation level the actions of the
STM however need to be broken down into
smaller actions sequences of smaller
actions so each action that I showed you
in a picture that the STM did before is
now as sequence of actions and where
does that sequence of actions come from
it's basically each line of code each
instruction in an implementation of an
STM function for instance to open for
update function think of each line as
one of the Epsilon's on the previous
slide and of course now they get
executions get to be internally that the
epsilon level for instance and open for
update by one transaction and validate
read by another one get to be
interleaved at this finer grain level
this is what complex that complicates
the picture so here's one picture with
the epsilon here's one picture again
with define lower level actions okay so
let me take a closer look at each of
these these functions we see that
typically they have one atomic read or
write of
shared data and the rest of the long
code for the function consists of local
variable accesses right this says to us
well all of these actions since they
touch only thread local data they can be
commuted they can be swapped with really
any other action except for this one so
commute everything to be adjacent to
this atomic read except there's a glitch
on this open for update function that
does an atomic read and later an atomic
compare-and-swap consider the following
scenario where two copies of this are
running I'm concurrently this one does
it read the other one does a compare and
swap as a result of which this compare
and swap fails now this cast and this
cast do not commute and this read and
this cast do not commute because they
all touch the same variable and these
are rights so we were hoping that we
would be able to compress the entire
method into one atomic action except it
didn't work here then we play a modeling
trick and we say we allow reads to be a
little looser we replace reads with
non-deterministic reads so
non-deterministic read can either be
nice and act like a regular read or it
can read on arbitrary value in which
case the cast associated with it in the
future must fail because it's going to
fail it doesn't really matter what it
read so remember we're not changing the
implementation we're just changing our
view our model of it we're adding to the
set of behaviors and if in this larger
set of behaviors we're still able to
prove serializability van then we're
safe and a non-deterministic read that
leads to a failed cast commutes with all
actions because it reads something
arbitrary it doesn't depend on any
action that came before it so now now
all of a sudden this non-deterministic
read can commute across this Cass to
come over here and the entire method is
compressed so
now we need one gray are one level of
transformation where we were able to
group all the actions that implemented
the STM functions into adjacent atomic
blocks yes that is think of that as the
breed threadlocal actions has that
confirms the value red is still the same
as one atomic action uh-huh I would also
be a valid way of thinking about yes yes
if I understood you correctly yes right
so we did one level of transformation
yes these meetings that the critical
point there is proof that if it is in
believe that the cast actually will fail
because if the Kraken of different Asian
depends on the fact that the cast's
reliable range detective feirense
economics right right so somehow I
didn't see how that bend into your
modeling trick so this cast um I mean
we're not just abstracting the read into
something more permissive casas are also
now aware of earlier reads that say
you're bound to fail it says if there's
an extra bit that says if someone does a
cast on what I read he's bound to fail
the ideal concurrent data types to
cassie's that succeed even though they
should fail which happens if you use
pointer values as your cash values and
happens sometimes is that a block gets
free and reallocating so you have a new
block which is the same pointer value as
the old one if you could get an
execution that the cars actually
succeeds even though it should fail it
was like changed I think change to act
right in this case the Casas on what's
called the STM word which includes a
version number inside and that always
gets incremented even though you may go
back to the same object same transaction
you'll have a bigger version number so
there are a lot of these implicit things
we know about the program that I'm
hiding under the rug
I mean when I said what the rest are
local accesses that is a fact that I'm
confirmed by inspection but right yes
the case then mean if I understand your
trick correctly is if you really
implement to that first read as just it
just really does return an arbitrary
value at runtime but the algorithm
indeed would be correct we just being
terribly inefficient because very seldom
would you get past the thick ass yes
correct that means it the way to think
laughs yes um because it says that says
that really what the memory system
should try to do is when you ask for to
read a value and you just try to predict
what value it was enter a future so you
can make progress but actually it's
allowed to return anything that it
pleases sure there are caveats I mean if
if you're returning a pointer to some
random corner of memory and then the
code here is chasing that pointer and
doing things you don't want your code in
between to crash right if you're reading
an integer it's fine if you're reading a
pointer to somewhere else yes from what
Sebastian said it seems like and there's
more than just those three conditions
for the STM to be correct for instance
there is this okay that's only in your
model that you're forcing the cast to
have this property that it's never going
to rewind no this is actually a property
of the particular STM implementation I
was looking at it just never rewinds and
of course version numbers wrap around
but mother with that caveat assuming
unbounded integers then it's a property
of the code itself it's not not part of
my modeling it's not something I added
in modeling and this similar trick comes
will come up in two more places in the
feet in the rest of this presentation
okay so we started at the implementation
level we obtained what I called course
atomic executions we grouped some
actions together now one
function in the SDM implementation we
can pretend this atomic now um this is
where boogie comes into the picture and
this is the part that had to do with the
work last summer now we're trying to
prove something called the non
overlapping rights pants property at the
low level which when transformed to an
algorithm level execution will imply the
exclusive rights property the exclusive
rights property as it stated of course
you can't check that on the
implementation level execution because
there isn't an explicit commit action
for instance there's a commit function
that consists of many other actions so
think of the non overlapping right spans
property as the implementation level
version of the exclusive rights property
that's in the implementers mind and here
what we checked was an interval where
tx1 opens an object for update and then
later closes it and another transaction
tx2 opens an object and closes it later
that these two intervals do not overlap
at all so this is the non overlapping
right spans property and after enough
transformations it implies the exclusive
rights property and the way we phrased
this condition and checked it with
boogie as a sequential check was as
follows we assume that TX executed an
open for update and it succeeded it has
not yet closed the object and then we
wrote a property that says at this point
TX is the exclusive owner of this object
right then if another transaction by
another thread called TX bad tries to do
an open for update it should fail and it
should not change this in Marion for
instance
so we start with an open for update by
the good transaction the object we say
assume that this open for update
succeeded TX good is the exclusive owner
of object now assume that there is
another transaction and that other
transaction tries to do an open for
update at the end of this it should
still be the case that TX good is the
exclusive owner so this is sequential
code but it's mimicking and interleaving
by two different threads by the fact
that TX patton TX good are two different
transactions and if you verify this and
if this check if this assertion check
passes in Boogie then you verified the
non overlapping right spanish property
this is the easier one the valid read
spans property which is going to
eventually imply Valladares property
that's the trickier one here TX one
opens an object for read and then later
successfully validates that read before
it commits a transaction in this
interval there should not be an overlap
with another transaction opening this
object for update and later closing it
in other words between the time I opened
it for read and then I validated it no
other transaction should be in the
process of updating that object so again
the sequential check formulated with
boogie goes as follows I open the object
for read I'm going to later validate it
and in the meantime I may also choose to
open it for update it all of these are
by the black good transaction TX but in
the meantime interference may happen
here here here and i'm going to show you
our model of interference on another
slide but if at the end of all of these
possible interferences at the end if
interference occurred if this is the
same as transaction having been
invalidated then that is what I want in
other words if if interference occurred
i want the transaction to be invalidated
if interference did not occur then the
transaction should I remained valid and
of course the smarts is in interfere
with here interfere with intuitively is
modeling the effects of pseudo regular
expression where the bad other thread
may close that word may open and then
later close that word or may open it and
leave it open so the way we model that
is in a while loop that are iterates an
arbitrary number of time times well we
pick a transaction non-deterministic way
that's different from the good
transaction that's going on and this TX
bad may open the object or update or may
close the object and this is an
arbitrary number of iterations of this
is what interference between my two
actions is to me
right so the engine name that seems like
it allows consecutive closes yes it does
but if if right and it also allows right
it allows closes without opens that
happened in the past or so you can't
think how this as more interference than
could happen but if I'm able to prove
correctness with this and I'm good SDM
implementation that way assumed the
correct pairing in order for the
correctness of its implementation so but
it could do arbitrary things like still
succeed if you missed everyone that I
think what you're saying you're saying
um this is too pessimistic a model of
interference and this may give you
scenarios that might not happen in your
real estate implementation and what I
actually have implemented is closer to
what you said where opens and closes
have to be matched but that makes for a
dirty slide think of this as again a
sketch of what I had for many reasons
including easier proof with boogie i did
pair opens and closes if they exist i'm
trying to model the case where there is
only a close or only an open without the
matching and other action so with this
model for interfere with this is the
assertion we check with boogie now
there's a while loop here and loops
create difficulty I need a pre and post
condition for for this while loop and
boogie has the abstract interpretation
and loop invariant inference capability
to actually infer what I need for this
loop but when I was trying to use it it
had a few bugs so I actually wrote by
hand a post condition for this loop
which basically said if someone
interfered with me then the version
number actually has been incremented and
I verified that this pre post condition
pair was indeed correct by doing
induction manually and the pre post
condition pair followed by one more
iteration of the loop implies the same
pre post condition pair and inductive
step so with that I was assured that i
had a correct pre and post condition for
loop which I then fed to boogie and
checked this scenario and I won't go
into the details but this approach found
some interleaving that had been
overlooked in the pseudocode for
instance the pseudocode in the pldi
paper had an omitted case a possible
interleaving of events at this level at
the end of which the transaction should
have been invalidated but it wasn't and
I also asked Tim Harris and others of
bugs that they had fun in the past but
that were corrected now of course and um
they told me those and when I modeled
them when I inserted them into the
pseudocode this approach was again able
to find that the right thing was not
being done in this case so um probably
from an STM implementers point of view
this is the most valuable part of what I
did where you have a mechanical way of
checking possibly the most difficult
part of this picture the rest is just
trying to put this into a formal context
and trying to make it stand together as
a big formal correctness proof but much
of that is manual and this is the part
that's automated and you can think of
this as checking whether the STM's way
of ensuring those three sufficient
conditions using its own metadata logs
etc is that correct or not right so
checking that I believe was where the
most value added was but from a grand
proof of correctness point of view we
have more work to do now we have M
course atomic execution and when there's
an and I'm not really telling you how we
got cereal and ooze but if you have the
non overlapping right spans and the
valid read spans properties you also get
the fact that when some transaction is
being undone nobody else actually really
interferes with it all right so a
rollback is
happening with no interference really as
a consequence of these two properties
let me show you the two more gray arrows
okay the first one has to do with
inserting a commit annotation if you
remember the OT FJ semantics said on
acid as commit so it was as if there was
an atomic marker of where the
transaction committed of course at the
implementation level there is no nice
clean here's the commit point marker I
need to insert that by hand and for a
successfully validated and committed
transaction that is after the first
successful validate read a comet
annotation is inserted there you can
think of this as I'm putting some
cosmetics on the implementation level to
make it look like an algorithm level
execution so here's where the commit
point is which means it is my goal to
commute all of the actions by TX next
two adjacent to this commit point which
with the validate non-overlapping
read/write spans and the valid response
properties happens it works so because
of those non-interference properties i
checked i know that none of these other
things that got interleaved are actually
dependent with these black guys so they
can all be commuted to wear this black
triangle is the rollback transactions
create some more difficulty with me
which with which we again fixed with
non-deterministic Ruiz so here is a
transaction being rolled back the old
values of everything that was written
are written back so object ones fueled
one is being reversed to what it was in
the beginning of the transaction etc etc
and the problem happens ok also this is
the cosmetics this is the taos in the
slide that I'm inserting it before each
one of these I insert at all saying an
STM implementation state transition
occurred you don't really need to pay
too much attention to
is but this is interesting I'm trying to
commute all of the transactions actions
over here except if while i was on doing
something i wrote before I did the undo
if some other transaction read it I mean
this red transaction is eventually going
to fail but I can't really commute these
two right because if I do then this
should I read something else so here is
a pesky read by a transaction that's
going to eventually fail but it's
breaking my commuting plan so what do i
do I again abstract this to a
non-deterministic read because in the
future it's going to fail the validate
is going to fail so when you change
reads to non-deterministic reads that
can read arbitrary values if they're
part of a rollback transaction then
these non deterministic reads get to
commute with everything and again
because I'm only adding to the set of
possible behaviors I'm not breaking any
safety proof if I can prove
serializability pure serializability
with these additional behaviors then
then I'm okay but now this forces need
to tweak the algorithm level semantics a
little bit too because at the algorithm
level also this this can happen and at
the algorithm level I'm trying to group
all the actions of a single transaction
together so at the algorithm level also
i need to allow failed reads that will
eventually doom the transactions and
there are 2 i'm adding to the set of
possible behaviors possible bad
behaviors so probably limas proofs would
probably very difficult to do with this
but if it's safe time after then then
this is ok to do
very actually he say for life Nance I
mean I could imagine that you know if
what if I'm doing one thread costs
another way to fit I mean is it safe
like oh let me say this is it live I
mean it's time clearly you have bad
non-deterministic reads happening all
the time and not know exact you shall
never gets to commit oxidation rate so
yes any property any Universal property
improve on the abstraction is when you
hold on the concrete project so if the
properties are not including lightness
properties if you are able to prove it
on the abstraction yes yes I'm saying it
will be difficult to prove with this
over approximation it will be difficult
to prove any liens recoges or any kind
of property you might create our
instruction on which you're not even a
full recovery all right yes I'm confused
in the previous introduction of
nondeterministic reads the value red was
input to the later Castro mystically
read something and confirm the
non-deterministic read I don't see where
that would be for this sort of manager
mr. so in this non deterministic read
the state of the STM is modified the STM
state that is taking care of this other
transaction so if I do a
non-deterministic read that reads an
arbitrary value I notify the STM of this
fact and later when this read is
validated even though it may not have
been touched in the meantime it will
fail in some way it's analogous to
phasing does it get beat writers yes yes
so in the semantics any transaction that
fails has to start from the beginning
and be retried transaction scale more
often yes oh the ransomware
but i think it's called my fault for
being confused but i think no be going
forward you're doing this now deter me
do you all reads nondeterministic yes so
all of the good cases are there because
in all of em all of the original
behaviors are there because in each case
the read can act the way it acted in the
original implementation but sometimes it
can read random garbage but in which
case that fact is communicated to the
STM the state has changed and although
there may not be any actual interference
the STM fails that transaction yes in
this particular scenario they're
guaranteed to be bad in this / IM doing
it in this particular case to allow me
to commute it over here because I want
to collect all the good black guys
together and this really is an
irrelevant read that will fail it's
immaterial that the weed got into lead
at that point another way to look at
this is I guess nevermind I mean this
really could have happened over there
but in the image case it would not have
been invalidated so um nevermind in this
in this particular scenario this
transaction was going to fail anyway I'm
not artificially making it fail you
don't have an execution in front of you
when you decide to abstract an action
you have programmed text in front of you
mm-hmm then you say okay I'm going to
extract this action mm-hmm and that
action once you decide to abstract that
abstract action could have executed
either in this kind of scenario or the
scenario where it should not have right
right right right then you're adding
more behavior yes but that's okay right
so I'm in that case more transactions
will get trial unrolled back and retried
unnecessarily
okay so after the cosmetic additions to
the implementation level executions
after you merge sequences of towels into
a single tile that sequences of change
of HTM internal state transitions into
one long single update of the ACM state
and after insert these marker actions
etc what you get and there's a simple
proof of this what you get is actually
an algorithm level execution according
to the high-level semantics and if you
proved these properties here at the top
level they implied exclusive rights
valid reads and the correct on those
properties so with all this manual
transformation abstraction etc I've
proved to you that every implementation
level execution is equivalent to an
execution that's an algorithm level
execution that has the ewv r and c you
properties therefore my model of the
bartok stn the executions it can
generate are all purely serializable so
um I have difficulty holding all parts
of this argument in my head a lot all
the time and so that's why I just want
to test my understanding I sure sure are
you saying that you verified every
implementation level execution satisfies
pure serializability I think what we
actually ended up verifying is that
quietly crazy abstraction of the actual
implementation satisfies is not just
those execution but not more exact you
should satisfy pure my love all this
extra monitor monism you are very
careful that you did not lose any of the
behaviors yes okay now you just added
all those extra behaviors to make the
proof easy mm-hmm which are allowed to
do so that's a very important point
right why do i do all of this because
the proof at this love
with all the interleaving that can
happen an inductive proof is very messy
very error-prone and it's difficult to
talk about on a program state and
something it's difficult to write
something you can say about it at this
level but after you swap enough things
you get an execution on which you can do
an inductive proof and you can rest
somewhat easier that inductive proof is
the it worked but now I mean the cost is
you don't get these very clean
properties that you can check at this
level you have to transform them to
something you can check along the way
right because you don't have these clean
commit points for instance at this level
so you have to check these somewhere
along the way something that's a
sufficient condition for these
conditions along the way that's reality
yes yes yes yes I guess time during
which bad things shouldn't happen
alright that's all true than you get
these nice properties yes I guess you
need to translate the concept of periods
up here to a concept of periods down
here and it's in this inescapable regret
I mean why do you need those properties
why can't you just think of one piece of
steak and you are just trying to
construct transactions at the top right
y-you me I don't say why you need those
properties this level you mean yeah so
your algorithm is also a program write
our story you are doing down there you
can keep doing that story until you get
all the way to a dalek actions ha but at
that very top level theatre saying I can
group everything that belongs to a
transaction together that is a manual
inductive proof and that proof needs
these properties why is it happening
well even if you mechanize it you need
you need these properties that say well
since the last transaction not committed
the following kinds of undesirable
things did not happen right and
the way I did that proof is by induction
on the number of committed or rolled
back transactions so to say something
about what happened since last time a
transaction committed or rolled back and
now this one to argue about what actions
may have transpired in between you need
these properties that say all but some
of some bad stuff did not happen they
say that like that or automatic pieces
is the party give you okay mmm how West
really is a way of completing the
picture basically making that all my
piece changes everything yes yes but I
mean executions at this level and at
this level are not the same and somehow
they need to be related to each other so
it's not just writing Greek letters it's
really making sure that reasoning at
this level carries over to the
implementation level but in terms of
catching bugs yes I mean this is the
part where you make this correspondence
is that you have these names for
operations that stay started to sing all
the way through thankfully the program's
actions are exactly the same right the
STM actions are first broken down
interleaved in many different ways then
through modeling fruits etc they're
grouped together two sequences of taos
you group them into one big action by
the HTML fermentation so what you get in
the end looks like an algorithm level
execution because down here you verify
these up at this level you get these and
if you have those then you have pure
serializability help the fact that the
basic operations at the very bottom you
can still recognize what they're doing
to himself yes yes that's true for all
kinds of a tank survive race no no no no
I mean it did help that when I was
writing the algorithm level semantics i
actually knew what was going on down
here so that if I Groot enough actions
together I would get for instance a
commit or rollback or something like
that right so the top level proof very
much has the logic of a lazy malla date
right in place STM in it the semantics I
provided for it has has that
characteristic in it and I mean that's
that's part of the reason the log is on
the program side and not on the STM side
at the program knows that it's a lazy
validate right in place not a slice
ability true the proof of correctness
and that is it's a pure serializability
remember if you throw away rollback
transactions what you should what you
get should be still an execution of the
program no conflicts and serializable
cereal you're confused complication why
you have to do it manually that the
program those universal quantifier over
the input program
so right so the top level correctness
proof has universal quantification over
threads transactions all possible
sequences of accesses you could have in
a transaction over objects etc and you
have to say something like since the
last commit point or since the last roll
back what happened in terms of program
state in terms of shared central store
it is as if only I executed and no one
else did I tend to say that you need to
say all my reads were valid no one else
wrote in the meantime and you know when
I wrote nobody else had the object for
right in the meantime so I'm the
execution actually really is purely she
realized just to argue that it is so you
need to have the assurance that between
open for update and validate nobody else
change the state you care about all you
needed to do that proof is that the
lower level thing implementation level
think would be abstracted into a
sequence of actions where each action
has a particular semantics yes I thought
the way you are using the semantics of
those actions yes so then why you need
what's simply nonsense to Sebastian's
question you said that there's some name
matching is important right lonely
matching is important you just need the
semantics of these actions no I mean
again this is happening because I didn't
tell the entire story of how the STM
works so before you commit um where's
look before you commit a transaction you
first validate all of your reads if they
were all valid then you close all of
your objects the commit point of this
transaction is after the first validated
read so I mean so yes you are going to
commute things together but to what
point to where the commit action
happened right i mean if you try to
commute these over here it won't work
so right i mean if you're grouping
things into bigger chunks but next to
what action are you grouping everything
together and you need to pick that
carefully i mean i didn't come up with
this commit point if you read a paper
about a lazy mile date right in place
STM they say yes this is the commit
point after the first successful
validate read remember in the higher
level there's one giant commit action
that says get rid of the logs go on okay
yes just pass with the introduction in
the second you said I'm not in German
little sure it's alright I understand
the first one I'm I think it's kind of
like value speculation and harder I'm
going to read a value speculatively I'm
going to compute some local things and
then I'm going to either throw it away
or use them based on what the value
actually is now under mystic in the
program text there you can say this
original reading the first reading
before the Cavs is going to be a
non-deterministic green I don't
understand here when you're reading the
value of the field as separate from the
value of the the tmw version number of
the object containing the field are you
in determining statically or dynamically
that it's not a terminus ting and what
do you confirm it with are you relying
on some some connection between the
version number and the value later we'll
see if so those seem very different
because the first case you're confirming
the actual value of the location
location you read and hear you're
reading something else to confirm the
valium or something red so let me tell
you my mental picture of it on maybe
that will help me beyond so if I'm a
field read when I'm about to occur I
make a decision I'm going to be regular
or I'm going to be crazy if I decide to
go crazy
I let the STM know you know eventually
when you try to validate me regardless
of what else may have happened in
between just invalidate i think i think
the tricky part is is that he actually
can see the future yes Pazzis given
entire execution then starts proof mr.
show right right I'm not changing the
implementation I'm changing the
semantics I assign to it therefore I can
make this read tell the STM that I went
crazy therefore invalidate this
transaction in the future so
transactions when they do a bad
non-deterministic read go into crazy
mode at the end of which they have to
fail and roll back I was suggesting that
you're changing the implementations
logic right you're not just abstracting
individual action what do you mean we
don't invite the esteem that you went
crazy original STM doesn't know anything
about crazy riding behavior right so
think of Andy Reid as different field
read where when I'm notifying the STM
there's another extra bit which I said
if I went crazy oh there's one bit I non
deterministically decide whether it's
you or one if it's zero I act normally
with STM act normal invalid invalidate
read it's as if this myth is set
regardless of everything else I just
failed this transaction then you created
a valid abstraction of the legal
execution because now your invitation
see you added an office very variable
right if you're available is just sort
of doing something right and you're not
influencing the implementation of the
behavior then you know by construction
that you have an abstraction but now how
do you know you have a stroke right so
one that bit is zero that gives me all
the original behaviors so remember this
bit is part of the STM implementation
therefore in terms of program variables
adding this has not changed anything now
all the original program behaviors are
there because they they all could happen
with this bit remaining at zero because
it was not
let's take Joyce units in a sense you
yes okay in that case Reid is the
regular read validate read is the
regular valid a tree if it's one they
act a little bit differently but this is
just all just additional behavior so but
this big was something you added
explicitly for the purpose of doing
proved right yes but it's in my mind is
the same as the read cars story and
since the abstracts the underlying
principles yes yes exactly all right so
try this one work very well if you try
to do a conductive proof because you
wouldn't know in advance whether the
weed is going to fail later on or not
right so is inductive proof I mean
you're given you're trying to show that
for all executions there exists an
atomic execution but instead of looking
at all execution trying to prove this
based on one step what you have to do it
I guess for all executions where these
bits play out to put it away
not only deserialize ability proof is
for all executions with the been set to
0 and 2 1 but remember if it's at the
one that transaction is rolled back so
all i care about is that roll back
executed correctly if it succeeded it
only succeeds when the bit is 0 think of
your actual implementation and then you
think of your more abstract behavior
where you choose to be crazy or not
uh-huh if you try to show that your
actual implementation refines your
specification he tried is using a
simulation at the time where it's time
to decide whether you're crazy or not
you don't actually know that you've got
that's true so at the time of proof of
serializability it's as if I can see
forward and backward through the entire
execution the fact you know that
checking that the U hat you did not
remove any implementation behavior
that's in your head right you don't
actually recognize it you don't
absolutely no no I mean there's um the
only part that's mechanized is the part
checked with Mooji all the rest is on
paper and pencil so that thought I think
if you try to recognize it you might
learn to problem you I mean it might not
be able to prove that you have more
behavior strictly more behavior in terms
of program variables I mean that some
money you have to show somehow that in
each step you are adding or behaviors
right the thing is that if you just take
an atomic an action of a program right
and you make it no more knowledge
understand no it's a very local check
that you added more behavior right but
in your case the argument for why you
added more behavior do not remove any
behaviors Lord lovel it requires all
this reasoning at here I'm setting this
bit and later on some access to that bit
is doing something whatever I'm just
saying I I believe that proof is easier
than you're thinking probably think of
the original state space and the
original behaviors and these other crazy
state spaces every so often you can't
jump to the crazy state space but you
come back and you can you come back you
know that you come back to the same
state well supposing there's a
transition back from the crazy stage
space to the lower state space right we
sent
back to what back to zero right mm-hmm
and the whole thing is screwed right
somebody has to check that can never
come back from the crazy skates faced
with a real streamspace right so I have
to argue to that when I come back to the
from the crazy state space back to
the real estate space that I come back
to the state I left in but that's easy
because all news are being done see
really um anyway all right so I I don't
know how to argue objectively whether
something is easy or not yes as I argue
more and more of this I realize that
more more of the proof needs to be done
mechanically and checked right the
cotton part that you take action
implementation you corazon it off by
showing you know that it is a comic I
think you mentioned one not determine a
degree trait which is yet you know sort
of a non just loves it that's it that's
it yeah restless Helen I'm adding cook
the rest it's automatic in the sense
that you see the text of the methods
that constitute the SDM implementation
and you see that each of them have
either a single shared variable access
or they have two of the format that i
showed you in which case the argument i
explained so that's yes yes right so to
summarize to formalize correctness i
define the language that had
transactions in it but not much more
defined pure serializability so I
haven't right so first remember this
serialize ability notion has nested
transactions inside it also and rolled
back transactions because it says it's
pure when you throw a rollback
transactions what you get is a still an
original program trace I wrote an
inductive correctness proof at the high
level which distilled the requirements
from the STM to these three properties I
related implementation algorithm
algorithm level traces for this I needed
to place on modeling tricks and this way
of relating the two executions allowed
each of these properties to be checked
mechanically on some model of the
implementation level execution and I
want to mechanize more of the proof look
at other kinds of STM's and see if a
modular and this transformation kind of
approach is applicable to them and what
I verified what I verified is still a
model of the implementation it's not the
c-sharp or C++ code and again it's at
the same level of granularity as the
real implementation but there is really
no formal relationship between my model
and the actual implementation so how to
make that more formal is something I
need to work on yes this is really
really future work to look at weak
memory models thank you one thing might
be interesting the Bartok lazy the
Bartok STM you modeled has the property
that if two transactions don't conflict
then they don't abstractly then they
don't reflect in their implementation
some other STM implementations don't
have that property like TL to in which
there's a global version number that
committing writing transactions
increment so two transactions that don't
have any intersection between the
reading right sets might actually in
conflict at the at the implementation
level so that might be an issue with
your sort your print out commuting based
from the witness trace that the
algorithm level can't be obtained by
simply commuting things you need to
throw away some stuff I guess
sometimes in that case even if
transactions are independent at the
higher level they might still be
conflicts at the lower level might
actually have asked the transition
transaction to retry aboard well know
that but but its atomic increments of
the shared variable and the the
correctness doesn't care which in that
case which what are they happening but
the values obtained would be different
what simply thought you did okay but for
the shared interval yeah but you can use
the same trick there also you can come
to the abstract and shared variable yeah
maybe it's a new style of abstraction I
mean in general I think one thing that
is going on in sirdar's proof is that
abstraction is a weapon for generating
more commuting actions right and I mean
that's not a domestic read is just one
kind of abstraction you can imagine lots
of different kinds of abstractions and
back typhoon is a student of Sardar he
working on a knife to that actually
tries to mechanize prospectors when
iterated computing arguments and
abstraction or anyone's actual original
II I had abstracted the cast to
non-deterministic we fail even when it
would have succeeded but this non
deterministic read seemed more widely
applicable so I thought one kind of
abstraction is better and if I
understand correctly what you are saying
and I do it I do what I call it throwing
away of rolled back transactions but I
do that only at the top level in what
you described I guess some of that
throwing away has to happen in the
intermediate steps where these failed
transactions have to be removed from the
trace okay
interesting example because shot is
right if you expect the actual number
and say it's just a unique identifier
then you commute at the problem then is
that in some cases it's actually a
number that is ordered because you care
about the order in reached us so you
have to when you do this abstraction you
have to know when is it just a guess
value invented actually and solar so I
think the thing is that as you keep
extracting the lowermost level rail you
do unis try different steps of the proof
at different levels at the point with
the actual value that number is
important at that point in crime that
abstraction but once you have taken care
of that part now your algorithm is a
little bit more abstract at that point
now you can just sort of toss it away
and you get more community room so it's
basically the different arguments are
going to happen in different parts of
the abstraction yeah and I I like to
think I'm not sure I can claim it but
that this is at least partly the picture
in the designers or implementers had
this is probably how he convinced or she
convinced herself that they implemented
transactions correctly otherwise I can't
imagine how they thought about all
possible interleaving zat that really
fine level and thought well regardless I
have something serializable
the UN you abstract away issues of
wrapping of version numbers yes and the
schemes for for dealing with that which
is a pretty important practical concern
are pretty damn salt if you're
interested in places where there might
actually be bugs that might be some
place to look at hmm what Tim did for
for Bartok in this area seems that could
be Finn's in a group might be really
interesting and other things I
abstracted away like I said when I say
only the red boxed lines touch shared
data and the others don't it's not
really immediately obvious for instance
if other code decided to behave badly
and chase pointers they could access
local data in other transactions erase
logs etc so either by inspection or
through static static analysis I need to
ensure that we part of the code I didn't
model isn't doing these evil things and
erasing other transactions logs etc from
your nap tomorrow the the counter as a
32-bit value rather than as a large kind
of internet but when you need just one
on that one to be going to generate the
others as much
just mama that's a tube in there exactly
you just want to know that when it wraps
over things don't commands oh did I we
interviewed by wait for two of the 32nd
to do too much okay thank you